réparer les vivants documentaires écrits
et réalisés par Florie Martin une
immersion vous venez de le voir au sein
de l'association woman safe basé à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui propose sous
un même toit l'accès aux soins la prise
en charge psychologique et un suivi
juridique pour les femmes victimes de
toutes formes de violence plus de 200000
femmes sont chaque année en France
victimes de violences conjugales
aujourd'hui comment espérer mieux les
protéger et mettre un terme à leur enfer
au quotidien nous allons débattre
maintenant sur ce plateau de débat doc
en compagnie de mes invités en
commençant par vous Laura bienvenue sur
ce plateau de débat doc voilà trois ans
et demi c'était dans la nuit du 16 au 17
avril 2018 et après plusieurs années de
violence conjugales et bien votre
conjoint a tenté de vous étrangler
c'était sous les yeux de votre fille qui
était alors âgées de deux ans vous avez
alors fini par porter plainte loin de
penser au parcours du combattant qui
vous attendez par la suite on y
reviendra dans cette émission votre
histoire vous en livrez quoi qu'il en
soit un récit à la fois poignant et sans
concession dans ce livre tweeté ou
mourir publier tout récemment chez
Michalon Twitter ou mourir parce que
c'est un message sur Twitter ce réseau
social qui vous le dites vous-même dans
cet ouvrage vous a permis de vous sauver
tout simplement Bérengère Couillard est
également à nos côtés bienvenue à vous
vous êtes député la République en marche
de Gironde co-auteur d'une proposition
de loi qui a été définitivement adoptée
en juillet 2020 concernant la protection
des victimes de violence conjugales bien
sûr puisque c'est notre sujet du jour et
ce texte faisait suite à ce Grenelle
consacré aux violences faites aux femmes
qui s'est déroulée durant tout l'automne
2019 on y reviendra également et puis
enfin avec nous à Cécile mayfer
bienvenue à vous et Cecile me faire
bonjour vous êtes la présidente
fondatrice de la Fondation des femmes
qui luttent au quotidien contre les
violences une femme les inégalités et le
sexisme dans tous les aspects de notre
société vous avez par ailleurs été
porte-parole puis présidente d'oser le
féminisme et vous êtes également auteur
de ce livre tu seras une femme guide
féministe pour ma nièce et ses amis
c'est un ouvrage publié aux éditions les
petits matins merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous en présidence d'emblée que votre
fondation vient de publier un rapport
consacré à l'hébergement pour les femmes
victimes de violence on y reviendra dans
un instant je me tourne tout de suite
vers vous parce que c'est vrai que
l'urgence pour ces femmes victimes de
violence c'est de quitter le domicile
conjugal de quitter cet enfer quotidien
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas quitté votre
domicile conjugal avant qu'on arrive le
drame d'avril 2018 vous concernant alors
au départ déjà je ne mettais pas des
mots sur ce qui se passait je ne me
disais pas victime de violences
conjugales déjà faut déjà réussir à se
dire dans peut-être qu'on est victime et
c'est plus difficile qu'on ne le pense
j'ai réussi quand même à partir une
première fois parce que là c'était le
matin c'était deux gifles de trop mais
je suis partie mais je les mets encore
ça faisait un an et demi qu'on était
ensemble il y avait déjà vu une
intervention de police et là c'était
trop et quelques mois après il est
revenu donc j'ai le droit à la
déclaration d'amour je vais changer je
t'aime je suis malheureuse sans toi et
je me suis dit on a tous le droit à une
seconde chance dans la vie surtout qu'il
avait eu une enfance un petit peu
compliquée aussi donc c'était un petit
peu comme on avait le syndrome de
l'infirmière je me suis dit avec moi je
vais réussir à le guérir et je suis
tombée enceinte donc au départ tout
était beau idyllique et au bout de cinq
mois de grossesse les coups ont repris
et j'ai pas compris ce qui s'est passé
en fait je pensais même pas que c'était
possible de frapper une femme enceinte
et je me suis complètement renfermée sur
moi et il y a eu la naissance de ma
fille où là il y avait quasiment plus
d'excuses en fait on est une famille on
est ensemble et là il y a eu plusieurs
interventions de police j'ai jamais
réussi à déposer plein de j'étais en
état de choc en état considération il
n'a jamais été arrêté à chaque fois
plusieurs interventions de police à
votre domicile il y en a eu un au
domicile de sa mère où les policiers
m'ont dit de déposer plainte de mais
j'étais en état de choc et j'ai pas
réussi à déposer plainte et les parties
avant et une troisième fois notre
domicile ou là il y a eu la police mais
c'était des menaces de mort avec un club
de golf et une bouteille d'eau qu'il a
mis sur ma fille une bouteille d'eau
froide alors qu'elle dormait et
néanmoins vous n'avez pas été jusqu'au
bout vous n'avez pas porté plainte non
parce que j'ai eu peur quand j'ai eu le
déclic j'ai demandé au policier si je
dépose plainte qu'est-ce qui va se
passer bah il m'a dit les menaces de
mort c'est à huis clos c'est sa parole
contre la mienne et la bouteille d'eau
froide qu'il a renversé sur ma fille
alors qu'elle dormait bah c'est pas des
coups mais qu'il allait prendre ma
plainte mais que il y aurait pas
beaucoup de suite et moi je connaissais
la dangerosité de mon ex-conjoint je me
suis dit si on me protège pas il va me
tuer et d'ailleurs le lendemain quand il
est revenu il m'a demandé si j'allais
déposer plein de je dis non il m'a dit
tu dépose plein de tes morts
tu es morte donc je connais très bien la
justice mon père était policier je vais
te faire passer pour folle hystérique et
en fait
menace sur vos parents aussi je crois
que le moment où parler de cette idée de
porter plainte contre lui quand je me je
le déclic en fait je me suis tant que je
serais pas ruée de coup on va pas me
protéger et je me suis dit alors est-ce
bien en espagnol
je protège ma fille c'est moi qui prend
les coups quand ils rentrons trop
alcoolisées qui va dans la chambre je me
suis dit au moins je me précipite je
suis là donc j'avais peur pour ma fille
et puis moi je savais qu'il allait
passer à l'acte au moment où j'allais
partir ce témoignage fait partie des
nombreux témoignages que vous avez pu
entendre pour traiter cette question en
votre qualité de co-auteur de ce fameux
texte de loi de juillet 2020 comment
persuader ces femmes et des femmes à
quitter le domicile avant toute chose
peut-être pour aller dans une
association comme woman safe par exemple
le problème numéro 1 c'est que ces
femmes quittent cet enfer c'est ça c'est
la fête la première chose une petite
sensibiliser vous le disiez tout de
suite c'est le fait de savoir que vous
êtes victime et d'avoir cette
possibilité de pouvoir de pouvoir parler
c'est évidemment d'avoir des numéros
d'écoute comme le 39-19 qui a été
d'ailleurs dans les horaires d'écoute
ont été élargi pour atteindre 24 heures
sur 24 jours sur 700
cet été tout à fait également toutes ces
woman safe la Maison des Femmes tous ces
lieux dédiés justement qui sont tenus
par des souvent par des bénévoles ou en
tout cas par des professionnels aussi de
santé qui permettent en tous les cas de
recueillir la parole c'est de former
évidemment les forces de l'ordre
policiers et gendarmes à mieux
recueillir la parole des femmes pour
sentir justement que ces victimes elles
sont elles peuvent aller parler en
confiance et ça je crois que c'est
absolument essentiel pour que demain
elle fasse le pas de partir du domicile
si elles sont évidemment en grand danger
ou même que la justice Vienne sortir
leurs compagnon du domicile parce que je
crois que ça aussi c'est le meilleur des
cas lorsque que c'est possible de le
faire
je faisais tout à l'heure référence au
rapport que vous venez de sortir c'est
c'est tout chaud et c'est évidemment à
l'occasion de de cette semaine de
mobilisation très forte dans le cadre de
la Journée internationale des violences
faites aux femmes ça sera ce 25 novembre
et vous nous dites dans ce rapport qu'il
manque 15000 logements d'urgence
d'hébergement d'urgence pour les femmes
victimes de violences conjugales le
constat est sévère de du côté de ce
rapport
disons que en fait ce constat il nous a
vraiment il nous a surpris même nous les
associations en fait on a souhaité faire
ce rapport parce que on avait besoin
d'avoir un peu un état des lieux de
l'hébergement d'urgence pour les femmes
victimes de violence parce que les
chiffres sont quand même un petit peu
difficiles à comprendre à savoir où sont
les places qu'est-ce qui se passe les
gouvernements annoncent qui créent des
places mais globalement on sait pas trop
où quoi quand comment donc on a voulu
faire le point là-dessus et en faisant
le point là-dessus on s'est rendu compte
qu'une femme sur victime de violence sur
6 va avoir besoin d'un hébergement
d'urgence dans le parc social donc à
nouveau c'est pas toutes les femmes
certaines pour certaines il vaut mieux
que ce soit le conjoint qui soit écarté
du domicile donc on ne dit pas que c'est
forcément la meilleure solution en tout
cas ce qu'on sait c'est que les femmes
ont besoin d'un hébergement et le
chiffre choc qui nous a vraiment sidéré
et qui a aussi été très révélateur de
des besoins en fait qui qui manquent
c'est le fait que on a regardé le numéro
115 c'est le numéro qu'on peut appeler
quand on demande un hébergement
d'urgence on a demandé au numéro 115
par rapport au nombre de femmes victimes
de violences qui appelaient combien
pouvait avoir un hébergement grâce à ce
dispositif et en fait il s'est avéré que
seul six femmes sur 10 on dit oui à 6
femmes sur 10 ça veut dire que
concrètement on dit non à 4 femmes sur
10 qui appelle chaque jour donc chaque
jour 4 femmes victimes de violence
conjugales sur 10 qui appelle qui ont en
10 ans qu'elles ont besoin d'un
hébergement d'urgence on leur dit non il
y a pas assez de place madame donc c'est
pour ça qu'en fait nous on en arrive à
la conclusion qu'il faut effectivement
démultiplier le nombre de places
disponibles pour les fins victimes de
violence parce qu'aujourd'hui les faits
montrent que ce n'est pas que ce n'est
pas suffisant une réaction à ce rapport
avec quatre femmes sur 10 qui ne
trouvent pas de logement d'urgence
justement oui avec ses enfants elle a
raison c'est à dire que le la demande
décroissante aujourd'hui et c'est tant
mieux il y a de plus en plus de femmes
qui qui ont ce souhait de quitter le
domicile parce qu'elle subissent ces
violences vous l'avez dit plus de 200000
femmes sont victimes de violences
conjugales chaque année donc on les
pousse à à partir et il faut pouvoir
justement les accueillir dans des
logements lorsqu'elles sont en grand
danger encore une fois et donc le
gouvernement depuis le début du
quinquennat a enfin augmenter de 60% le
nombre de places donc on est passé de
4600 places à 7700 places aujourd'hui
opérantes voilà on a également augmenté
le prix de la nuitée parce que c'est
important de le dire parce que on a
augmenté 10 euros le prix de la nuitée
ce qui permet en fait aux associations
de mieux accueillir ces femmes mais en
effet la demande est croissante et il
faudra sûrement encore plus de place
pour pouvoir accueillir ces femmes dans
les bonnes conditions parce que
aujourd'hui on a des femmes qui sûrement
ne peuvent pas avoir ces logements-là je
crois aussi que il faut et ça c'était
une promesse qui avait été faite pendant
le Grenelle et qui va venir réalité
c'est d'avoir une cartographie des
places disponibles parce qu'aujourd'hui
il y a des associations qui ne savent
pas par exemple qu'une autre association
a une place disponible et donc ce serait
utile sur un territoire donné d'avoir
les places disponibles et ça ça va être
possible incessamment sous peu ça m'a
été confirmé par par le ministère voilà
c'est tout ça qu'il il faut qu'on arrive
à faire pour que ces femmes soient le
mieux accueilli parce que il faut que
justement ces femmes qui ont besoin de
quitter le domicile puissent le faire
dans les meilleures conditions quelques
chiffres pour resituer l'ampleur du
problème d'un autre pays ce chiffre
qu'on répète depuis le début de cette
émission que vous venez de répéter plus
de 200000 femmes chaque année sont
victimes de violence conjugales dans
notre pays 80% des plaintes pour
violence conjugales sont classées sans
suite et on va en parler dans un instant
et puis enfin 80% des femmes victimes de
ces violences sont des mers et donc ont
des enfants on en reparlera aussi dans
dans cette émission on va voir un
extrait du documentaire ce sont des
cours à donner par cette association
woman safe auprès d'agents de sécurité
d'agent de police pour savoir comment il
faut réceptionner ces femmes notamment
bien sûr dans les commissariats comme
vous preniez conscience que pour moi une
victime c'est quelqu'un qui rentre la
première fois au commissariat c'est à
dire c'est pas un monde où on est
habitué à rentrer en fait ce qu'elles
vont vous déclarer vous paraîtra pas
très clair mais parce qu'elle est
stressée il faut vraiment que vous
considériez que la victime elle est
complètement terrorisée de devoir venir
vous voir à un moment il faut que nous
aussi pour les séances soient capables
de regarder nos nos travers en face et
nos failles et dire alors je vous le dis
pas pour vous je dis pour moi parce que
vous venez d'arriver donc vous tomberez
pas dans ces travers là
on a pendant très longtemps mis en doute
la parole des victimes quand la victime
elle arrive ne vous faites pas des nœuds
au cerveau oui mais là elle dit que
depuis 10 ans mais là elle a pas elle
dit qu'il la giflé elle a pas de trace
elle a pas oh stop la victime on verra
tout à l'heure elle arrive elle veut
déclare un truc vous la croyez déjà
porter plainte ça semble vraiment un
obstacle prépondérant alors pour les
raisons que vous nous avez expliqué tout
à l'heure Laurent il s'agit de sortir de
cette emprise et d'avoir la force de le
faire combien de femmes victimes de
violences conjugales portent plainte
aujourd'hui en France à peu près en
pourcentage je vais lui le livre dans
environ 18 à 20% oui c'est très faible
c'est très très faible ce chiffre en
exergue un 80% des plaintes pour
violence conjugales sont classées sans
suite parce que vous vous avez bel et
bien porter plainte Laura mais alors
qu'elle fut votre surprise ensuite par
exemple de voir dis-moi après son
incarcération vous apprenez par hasard
presque par hasard que votre conjoint
était libéré sans suivi son bracelet
électronique et que vous vous êtes en
danger c'est terrible ça j'étais en état
de choc sachant que j'ai déposé plein
donc à partir du moment j'ai déposé
plainte j'ai donné aussi quelque part je
me suis je vais faire confiance aux
policiers bon ils ont été bienveillants
à la justice et là j'ai pas compris ce
qui s'est passé et fait une demande de
mise en liberté au mois de décembre
c'est refusé même on appelle et un mois
et demi après le 14 février il a été
libéré en attente de son procès et je ne
suis même pas au courant et le pire dans
tout ça c'est qu'il donne un lieu de
résidence que je connais une vieille
maison qu'il avait hérité de ses parents
et on a même pas vérifié un lieu qui
était inhabitable on vérifie même pas le
lieu où cet homme est censé être donc
c'est moi qui engage un détective privé
à mes propres faits pour prouver qu'il
en freinait son contrôle judiciaire et
qu'il était en région parisienne et là
un silence de la justice trois mois
d'infraction à un contrôle judiciaire et
l'agence d'instruction n'a pas répondu
une seule fois à mon avocate et vous
dites dans votre livre que finalement la
justice
fait davantage peur aux victimes qu'elle
ne fait peur aux agresseurs c'est
terrible de dire une chose comme ça
c'est comme ça que vous l'avez vécu
votre parcours judiciaire la justice
elle fait peur aux victimes quand j'ai
vu qu'on pouvait enfin là j'ai failli
mourir sous les yeux de ma fille et on
remet toujours en question en fait
finalement notre parole tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps c'est
toujours à la victime de prouver et je
me suis rendu compte que c'était la
jungle en fait les textes de lois ils
étaient pas respectés parfois on a les
leurs avocats qui font ce qu'ils veulent
eux ils ont tous les droits voilà et
c'est toujours de la victime ils ont
toujours des excuses lui par exemple il
a dit qu'il est en France en contre
judiciaire parce qu'on l'a privé de sa
fille parce que j'étais très méchante et
c'est à la limite il a pas été glorifié
pendant le procès d'assise d'avoir enfin
son contrôle judiciaire et là vous vous
dites c'est surréaliste c'était moi la
méchante donc
enfin c'est un monde oui moi je fais de
la souffrance rajouter la souffrance
est-ce que vous dites aussi dans votre
livre
ça faisait 10 mois que je sortais que
j'étais en arrêt de travail j'avais
enfin repris ma vie à mi-temps
thérapeutique et franchement ils ont
brisé ma vie Anne-Cécile m'a fait
comment est-ce qu'on explique cela et
comment est-ce qu'on peut un temps soit
peu et hermédié 80% des plaintes pour
violence conjugales ne sont classées
sans suite c'est énorme il y a très peu
de plein de déposés au regard du nombre
de violences commises
oui et d'ailleurs une partie des
féminicides qu'on voit tous les ans ce
sont des féministes qui sont dus à
d'énormes successions de
dysfonctionnements comme l'a dit Laura
elle a eu beaucoup de chance en fait de
réussir à s'en sortir et c'est parce
qu'elle a mis énormément de d'énergie et
qu'elle a appelé à l'aide mais beaucoup
de femmes aujourd'hui sont victimes de
féminicides on est quand même là on est
à 102 je crois là au 22 novembre ce qui
était le chiffre du au 31 décembre
l'année dernière donc vous voyez qu'on a
une augmentation cette année et souvent
c'est dû à des dysfonctionnements ces
dysfonctionnements c'est à la fois un
manque de formation ça là-dessus je
pense que tout le monde est d'accord et
puis il y a un effort qui est fait sur
la formation de la part du gouvernement
et des gouvernements précédents aussi
mais c'est pas suffisant moi je pense
qu'il y a deux choses qui doivent
s'ajouter à la formation il y a
obligatoirement des moyens c'est à dire
que quand les policiers sont appelés par
des tas de gens sur des tas de crimes et
délits différents dans la même journée
il va falloir qu'il priorise ils peuvent
pas aller partout et en fait il peut
s'avérer qu'ils vont prioriser d'autres
choses donc ça c'est la donc la première
chose c'est les moyens il faut qu'il y
ait plus de de force de l'ordre qui soit
en capacité de répondre qui soit formée
qui soit dédié à ces sujets là et puis
ensuite c'est lorsqu'ils sont pas assez
nombreux quand on priorise il faut que
en priorité ce soit les violences
conjugales parce que c'est des femmes en
danger de mort donc en fait pour moi ça
doit être plus prioritaire que qu'autre
chose donc ça c'est une décision
politique et on a vu que c'était
possible de faire mieux parce que début
2020 moi je le dis j'ai trouvé que
vraiment quand ça se passe bien je suis
la première à le dire pour moi début
2020 la réaction des forces de l'ordre
la réaction de la justice la réaction du
gouvernement des associations de tous
les gens qui ont fait des dons aussi on
a reçu beaucoup de dons à la Fondation
des femmes à ce moment-là on a fait un
travail exceptionnel tous et toute main
dans la main et on a réussi à faire
baisser le nombre de féminicides parce
que la réponse était immédiate qu'elle
était appropriée elle était bien et là
malheureusement depuis plusieurs mois on
voit que les choses reviennent un petit
peu les mauvaises habitudes reviennent
un peu au galop et donc c'est vrai qu'il
faut une reprise qu'il faut constamment
mettre ce dossier au dessus des autres
et surtout quand les moyens sont pas
encore suffisants c'est vraiment un jeu
de priorité quoi de qui passe c'est
horrible mais c'est quel est le sujet le
plus important pour le ministre de
l'Intérieur aujourd'hui il faut que ce
soit les violences conjugales ça ne peut
pas en être un autre et vous parlez des
féminicides dans les derniers chiffres
dont on dispose du côté du ministère de
l'Intérieur nous font part de 102
féminicides en 2020 contre 146 une année
plutôt en 2019 peut-être en léger
progrès en juger par par ces chiffres
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas des tribunaux
spécialisés comme ça existe en Espagne
par exemple pour traiter ce type
d'affaires et que ces affaires
aboutissent et que les victimes et gain
de cause il en a été question d'ailleurs
il y a eu un rapprochement entre le
civil et pénal qui a été opéré depuis le
vote de la loi justement donc de juillet
2020 on va attendre de voir comment les
choses s'organisent moi j'étais plutôt
favorable à la création de tribunaux
spécialisés comme c'est le cas en
Espagne au sein de les deux on on n'a
pas exactement le même fonctionnement
judiciaire et c'est vrai que il y a un
avantage à créer ces structures
spécialisées après moi je voulais
rebondir sur ce que disait Anne-Cécile
milfaire sur le fait que il faut
prioriser il faut que les forces de
l'ordre priorisent les violences
conjugales et je peux je peux dire que
c'est déjà le cas quand on voit par
exemple qu'il y a de plus en plus de
réorganisation des cellules de police et
gendarmerie moi je vois sur mon
territoire on a inauguré en décembre de
l'année dernière une cellule dédiée aux
atteintes aux personnes uniquement donc
les victimes de violences sexistes
sexuelles et conjugales je trouve que
c'est absolument primordial d'avoir
justement ces forces de l'ordre donc là
c'était une gendarmerie mais ça peut
être aussi police parce que la police
fait également le même regroupement et
donc c'est dédié uniquement assez
victime là et ce sont du personnel qui
est formé et qui est volontaire
justement pour recueillir donc la parole
de ces victimes et également faire le
lien avec les tribunaux parce que c'est
là qu'on voit
la nécessité d'avoir justement cette
coordination locale vous le disez tout à
l'heure Laura c'est le fait d'avoir tout
le monde qui puisse échanger et il va y
avoir aussi la création d'un de la liste
de d'un fichier donc de d'auteur de
violence conjugales et je crois que
c'est absolument nécessaire pour que la
préfecture les forces de l'ordre
également le personnel pénitence
pénitentiaire puisse avoir connaissance
de ces auteurs de violence parce que il
faut qu'on puisse protéger les victimes
et là c'est vrai que votre témoignage il
est terrifiant quand on voit ce qui vous
est arrivé le fait que vous ne vous ne
soyez pas au courant de la sortie de
votre ex-conjoint de prison et on a vu
aussi notamment avec les féminicides
d'ailleurs et de Mérignac les
dysfonctionnements donc je crois que
c'est absolument nécessaire qu'on arrive
à à coordonner tous les acteurs ensemble
pour qu'il n'y ait plus justement ces
manquements et que vous soyez enfin les
victimes sont informés et puis que toute
la chaîne des acteurs qui peuvent qui
peuvent agir soit au courant veut réagir
allez-y je vous en prie
dans le sens de Madame la député c'est
vrai que c'est pour
nous faire mes victimes au centre de
faire en sorte qu'on comprenne leur
problématique et qu'en fait on s'adapte
à ça et non l'inverse qu'on demande pas
une femme qui est victime qui est polie
traumatisée de comprendre et de
s'adapter un système qui est très
compliqué avec des acteurs qui sont pas
forcément formés donc en fait se mettre
à la place des femmes c'est par exemple
les informer en temps réel de là où on
est leur plainte le nombre de femmes qui
disent ben moi j'ai porté une deux trois
fois plein je ne sais pas où ça en est
je ne sais pas où elles en sont je ne
sais pas si je suis protégée ou pas elle
ne savent pas ce qui se passe et
effectivement ne savent même pas lorsque
leur ex-conjoint sont sortis de prison
si par exemple ils sont sortis de prison
plus tôt jusqu'à présent il y avait
aucune obligation dans l'informer la
victime donc clairement on voit que
c'est un qu'on se met pas à la place des
femmes et il faut inverser ça a changé
de regard se mettre à leur place
comprendre comment il fonctionne pour
pouvoir mieux les protéger et aussi pour
pouvoir pour faire en sorte qu'elle se
protège elle-même et on l'a vu dans le
féministe de Mérignac ne pas informer
madame Chainez ne pas l'informer en fait
de ce qui se passait sur son dossier
c'est la mise en danger aussi parce que
résultat ne pouvait pas se protéger elle
ne savait pas où on était son dossier
elle ne savait pas que son ex-conjoint
était dehors elle ne pouvait pas se
protéger comme elle aurait pu si elle
avait été bien au courant de ce qui se
passait au niveau de la police ou de la
justice on va voir un deuxième extrait
de du documentaire avec cette fois le la
parole des des femmes bien sûr victime
de violence mais qui parle des enfants
regardez les enfants ils ressentent je
pense que un genre de Don bivalence
parce qu'ils ne savent pas de quel côté
se plaçait pendant les crises c'est sûr
qu'ils sont de côté de la victime des
crises mais après il commence à se poser
des questions et comment c'est presque à
sentir
un genre d'inquiétude pour c'est pour ce
papa
qui qui a une victime de lui-même
après je pense que avec le recul ils
arriveraient à relativiser en disant
effectivement elle a bien fait de pas
j'ose espérer que ils vont pouvoir faire
ce chemin là et puis quelques chiffres
pour compléter cette extrait du
documentaire 143.000 enfants sont
concernés par ces violences faites aux
femmes 97% des femmes victimes indiquent
peur anxiété angoisses et stress chez
leurs enfants dans 40 à 60% des cas le
conjoint violent exerce des violences
physiques sur son enfant et
72,6% des mers obtenant une ordonnance
de protection doit exercer l'autorité
parentale avec le conjoint violent Laura
vous avez été confronté également bien
entendu à ce sujet avec votre petite
fille d'abord est-ce qu'elle va bien
aujourd'hui elle a 6 ans nous sommes
quatre ans après les faits et ce qu'elle
va bien elle va mieux elle a eu quand
même un suivi depuis ces deux ans et
demi depuis la tentative de meurtre avec
un pédopsychiatre victimologue
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est quand mon
ex-conjoint est parti en prison
j'ai dû saisir le juge aux affaires
familiales et ça ça a pris plusieurs
mois donc en attendant comment fait-on
les soins c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
a des médecins qui agissent en
contrebande parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut
quand même l'accord des deux parents
donc ça aussi c'est pour ça que moi je
plaisais pour une suspension de
l'autorité parentale pour les tentatives
de meurtre parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que c'est très compliqué
pour les soins pour l'inscription à
l'école c'est pareil on a eu énormément
de mal à inscrire ma fille à l'école
j'ai dû hurler à la mairie et brandir
mon dépôt de plantes devant tout le
monde j'avais l'impression d'être
humilié puisque mais le père enfin je
peux très bien mentir d'ailleurs qu'il
est en prison et qu'il n'y ait pas donc
c'est un combat donc j'ai eu l'autorité
parentale exclusive mais on a quand même
prévu en cas de sortie de mon
ex-conjoint des visites médiatisées et
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est quand il est
sorti de prison il m'a signé tout de
suite au JAF alors moi j'ai dû à
attendre plusieurs mois pour avoir une
date lui en deux trois semaines il avait
déjà une date et justement on lui a
accordé des visites médiatisées mais je
dis que l'état de ma fille le médecin
l'a dit que c'était pas possible de
mettre en lien ma fille avec son
bourreau en fait donc du coup je me suis
un petit peu mise hors-la-loi et puis
bon il a été remis en détention
provisoire donc il y a pas eu de visite
médiatisée
je me suis battue pour porter ma fille
participe au procès d'assis parce que
pour moi un enfant témoin des violences
conjugales et d'une tentative de meurtre
est une victime alors elle a été
reconnue comme victime comme victime vu
que l'on a octroyée des dommages
intérêts mais la Cour a refusé la
déchéance en disant que la tentative de
meurtre en présence de baffine remettait
en aucun cas en cause ses qualités
paternelles donc je me suis battu
jusqu'en appel et le 21 septembre 2020
j'ai obtenu mon ex conjoint était déchu
de ses droits parentaux absolument votre
ex-conjoint qui s'appelle Frédéric a été
condamné à 8 ans de réclusion crinelle 5
ans de suivi sociaux judiciaires il a
été déçu de ses droits parentaux en
appel autrement dit que vous avez gagné
sur toute la ligne ça valait le coup de
porter plainte ça va aller le coup de de
mener ce combat judiciaire et Dieu sait
s'il a été vous concernant je regrette
pas d'avoir déposé ma plainte pour ma
fille parce qu'elle est protégée si
j'avais pas eu ma fille je pense que
j'aurais retiré à mon dépôt de plainte
parce que c'est franchement les portes
de l'enfer c'est énormément de
souffrance
j'imagine bien sûr la situation de ses
enfants qui sont aussi des victimes de
ces violences conjugales bien sûr il y a
des enfants covidim de violences
conjugales et aussi des enfants
collectifs de féminicine puisque chaque
année il y a environ 50 enfants qui sont
tués par leurs parents pour pour faire
pression sur la mer donc par leur père
pardon pour pour faire mal à la mer donc
c'est vraiment les enfants sont aussi
des objets dans dans la dans la haine et
dans la férocité du conjoint violent ce
qu'il faut vraiment retenir c'est que un
mauvais mari n'est jamais un bon père
jamais jamais donc ça c'est quelque
chose sur lequel qu'on arrive petit à
petit je trouve à faire prendre
conscience à faire comprendre mais ça
reste encore et là on le voit sur
tentative de meurtre c'est fou qu'en
fait on dise un qui a fait la tentative
dotée la mère à son enfant peut encore
prendre des bonnes décisions sur
l'avenir de son enfant alors qu'il a
essayé de lui enlever sa mère comment
est-ce qu'on peut penser que ce genre de
personne ce genre d'individus peut
prendre des bonnes décisions pour
l'avenir de ses enfants c'est un
supportable et le combat de Laura là
dessus et absolument nécessaire et
fondamental récemment je discutais aussi
avec un
une personne dans sa fille a été victime
de féminicides et qui me disait qu'il
avait la garde de ses petits-enfants
mais que ça a été très difficile et que
depuis la prison celui qui avait tué la
mère donc de ses enfants ne voulait pas
perdre la garde il s'opposait à ce que
ce grand-père amène ses petits-enfants
chez un psy donc en fait vous imaginez
que ces deux petits enfants ont perdu
leur mère elle a été assassinée par leur
père et leur père
interdit ils aillent voir un psy c'est
ça en fait l'autorité parentale et
évidemment qu'il se servent de
l'autorité parentale pour continuer à
faire pression sur la famille de la
victime ou sur leurs enfants donc c'est
vraiment l'autorité parentale et la
manière dont effectivement les mères qui
se débattent comme pas possible pour
essayer de protéger leurs enfants d'un
père violent c'est fou à quel point
c'est c'est compliqué encore et il
faudrait vraiment pouvoir réussir à
faire en sorte que on aille plus loin
dans la protection des enfants et donc
dans la décence de l'autorité parentale
de manière plus systématique vous pouvez
réagir bien sûr mais je partage je
partage l'objectif c'est les enfants
sont des victimes collatérales des
violences conjugales c'est vrai que
c'est la première fois en tous les cas
en septembre 2019 qui a un Premier
ministre qui dit clairement que un mari
violent n'est pas à mon père et c'était
évidemment très important de le dire au
lancement du Grenelle Évian se
conjugales aujourd'hui on a eu enfin à
terme du Grenelle des violences
conjugales on a eu deux lois qui
notamment status sur la garde et
l'autorité parentale et donc et c'est
quand même aussi la première fois qu'on
met noir sur blanc dans le texte que
automatiquement la garde est retirée
donc quand il y a féminicide et c'est
vrai qu'on laisse à l'appréciation du
juge pour le retrait en cas de violence
conjugales il est très difficile dans le
droit et parfois j'en ai c'est de le
faire je vous assure en tant que
législateur c'est peut-être
difficilement compréhensible ça de voir
les droits parentaux maintenus à
l'agresseur c'est tout à fait c'est
parce qu'en fait on laisse le juge c'est
notre État de droit fait que notre le
juge doit décider en fonction de la
situation alors évidemment moi je serais
très tenté d'avoir de faire ça de
manière automatique la vie n'est pas
aussi simple et notre droit nous permet
pas l'automaticité aussi facilement donc
l'automaticité elle est dans le cas de
évidemment de féminicides où là il y a
une automaticité je tiens à souligner
que ce n'était pas le cas avant la loi
il n'était pas rare d'avoir des des
pères qui avaient tué la mer et qui
gardaient l'autorité parentale en prison
donc voilà aujourd'hui on avance mais il
est aujourd'hui dit noir sur blanc qu'il
est
vraiment préférable il faut le faire il
faut retirer l'autorité parentale un
parent violent parce que il est
forcément un mauvais parents et la
reconnaissance des enfants comme étant
des victimes ça remonte à aujourd'hui
dans notre fonction ça fait ça fait très
longtemps que l'enfant est considéré
victime mais en fait dans les faits dans
la loi ça fait longtemps que on a un
arsenal législatif mais il est pas
toujours très précis sur les cas de
violences conjugales et donc forcément
l'enfant a souvent été minimisé dans les
affaires c'était des affaires
donc moi ma fille normalement c'est
censé une circonstance aggravante de
faire des violences devant les enfants
dans la motivation de la cour d'assises
mon ex-conjoint après 8 ans donc il a
encouru la perpétuité et il y a bien
marqué que c'est le fait qu'il soit à
perte ça diminuer sa peine donc
c'est-à-dire que en plus d'avoir des
textes de loi qui ne sont pas appliquées
ça se retourne contre nous être la
compagne bah finalement je l'ai cherché
c'était ma faute l'alcool qui est une
explication devient une excuse oui mais
madame fallait le mettre en coeur de
désintoxication donc c'est de ma faute
je l'ai peut-être cherché la présence
d'un enfant bah vous avez pas protégé
vos enfants et les enfants sont les
fantômes de la justice et vous voyez ça
fait diminuer des j'ai de nombreuses
victimes qui nous disent oui mais
monsieur on va pas le mettre en prison
il est père donc enfin c'est quand même
hallucinant mais au-delà de la peine il
y a aussi la lutte contre la récidive je
tiens quand même aussi à signaler ça
c'est que on a toujours mis et c'est
bienheureux du budget et on en met
encore plus cette année pour les
victimes de violences conjugales mais il
y a aussi les auteurs parce qu'il y a 40
% de récidive et dans le cas de votre de
votre écran joint c'est une personne qui
aurait dû être accompagné dès les
premiers coups qui ont été pris et donc
là on met en place des centres la
journée en inaugure 1 ce jeudi à
Bordeaux il y en a 18 qui ont été créés
en 2020 12 qui sont créés cette année
partout en France sur le terrain donc
sur le territoire et également dans les
doms pour traiter ces auteurs c'est à
dire qu'on va justement les accompagner
dans lorsqu'ils sont qu'ils ont des
problèmes d'alcool ou de drogue
également les accompagner à retrouver un
emploi parce que ce sont des personnes
qui sont souvent éloignées de l'emploi
et surtout les accompagner
psychologiquement et si on arrive
justement parce que ça n'enlèvera pas la
peine qu'il vous a fait mais on va faire
en sorte que cette personne justement ne
récidive pas avec une autre femme à
l'avenir pour éviter justement ces
récidives qui sont
finisse par parler du de la
généralisation du bracelet électronique
pour éloigner évidemment le le conjoint
violent de la victime Anne-Cécile me
faire est-ce qu'on a fait des progrès
sur ce sujet
alors il faudrait qu'on puisse avoir une
étude d'impact des bienfaits du bracelet
nous on était vraiment favorable à la
mise en place durant l'électronique à sa
généralisation maintenant ce qui pour
l'instant manque c'est qu'on puisse se
rassembler avec les pouvoirs publics et
les associations qui tous les jours sont
en train de voir comment ça se passe
parce qu'il y a des problèmes il y a ce
bracelet malheureusement qu'on puisse
qu'on puisse bien faire le point
ensemble pour s'assurer que c'est un
dispositif qui fonctionne vraiment et
donc là pour le moment c'est là où le
bât blesse un petit peu c'est dans le
suivi l'évaluation la mesure d'impact de
ce programme il a bien été lancé mais
encore faut-il qu'on puisse travailler
ensemble à s'assurer que que ce soit
bien mis en place partout pour que ça
fonctionne et là on n'est pas encore
tout à fait bien en place voilà
on donnera le mot de la fin bien sûr à
Laura simplement pour dire à Anne-Cécile
mais Lefer qu'il y a justement des
attentes de remonter statistiques pour
s'assurer que ce soit bien mis en place
sur l'ensemble des juridictions
aujourd'hui ce que je peux dire c'est
qu'il y a 1000 bracelets anti
rapprochement disponibles et qui aurait
plus de 400 qui sont aujourd'hui pro
donc déjà déjà établi enfin mis en place
en tout cas donc on va voir comment les
choses comment les choses évoluent en
tout cas aujourd'hui il y a des
bracelets anti rapprochement disponibles
donc le Garde des Sceaux a fait un
rappel à l'ensemble des juridictions
pour s'assurer que il pense au roi
rapprochement pour toutes les victimes
de violences conjugales lorsque
évidemment c'est nécessaire mais on
attend les retours statistiques pour
s'assurer que c'est bien mis en place
partout parce que le but c'est que ce
soit dans tous les départements partout
en France le arabe j'ai gardé le
meilleur pour la fin le titre de votre
livre
raconter nous pourquoi ce ce tweet vous
a sauvé la vie c'est comme ça que vous
le décrivez dans ce livre
conjoint était libéré que je l'ai appris
j'ai su ce jour-là que la justice
m'avait abandonné que là ça allait être
un combat pas que tout le monde pas que
contre mon ex conjoint mais également
contre la justice et quand j'ai vu que
il avait un frein à plusieurs fois son
contre judiciaire et que la justice ne
faisait rien bah du coup je me suis dit
voilà faut que je trouve d'autres
solutions pour sauver ma vie celle de ma
fille du coup j'ai utilisé
je regrette pas il y a aussi des belles
choses sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
une belle chaîne de solidarité qui s'est
mis en place j'ai pas pensé aux
conséquences et une semaine après il a
été remis en détention provisoire en
tout cas c'est une place pour la prise
de parole des victimes on le voit de
plus en plus c'est pas uniquement pour
les violences dont on a parlé
aujourd'hui puis on va finir là-dessus
il y a un téléfilm qui va raconter votre
histoire très bientôt sur les écransm6
je crois tout à fait alors ils seront
premiers en Belgique mercredi
et c'est un téléfilm qui est inspiré de
mon histoire et de celle de Julie
douille donc je l'ai vu la semaine
dernière c'est
il est très réaliste il est très
difficile à regarder et sortira
prochainement dans d'ici quelques mois
sur le courage que vous avez eu tout au
long des obstacles que vous avez vu à
franchir dans dans votre vie récente
tweeté ou mourir votre histoire est à
lire
chez Michelon de votre livre qui vient
de juste d'être publié puis il y aura ce
donc ce téléfilm bientôt sur sur chez
nos confrères de M6 merci un grand merci
vraiment à toutes les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat doc aujourd'hui
vous réactions ce sera sur hashtag
débadoc sur Twitter merci à celle
massali qui m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission comme à l'accoutumée je vous
donne rendez-vous pour un prochain débat
doc ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]